what's the definition of a cinephile I
guess it the definition of a cinephile
is like a person who who really truly
loves movies and supports them I mean
like you know I was a film collector
like you know I was I was the kid who
like you know growing up I watched every
movie that came out I would you know I
would look for the obscure films i would
go to the local video store and like
rent anything and i'd talk with the
video Clerk and be like hey which what
movie can I get and like they'd
recommend stuff and I look for stuff and
like that's how I found out about old
boy and ichi the killer and all that
stuff from like you know the local
people at the video stores and like I
would go one of my favorite pastimes is
I would go to like you know like
blockbuster 2020 video and like rummage
through for like hours through like the
five for 20 bins and like buy as many
movies as I possibly could I have a DVD
collection of 6,000 movies um and like
you know I had made some good money like
doing like like promotions for for first
you know events and stuff before i got
into movies when I was like younger I
did that and I also like worked in a
restaurant and I took all the money that
i had saved up which was like a couple
grand and instead of going to film
school you know I I was gonna make my
pure joy and stuff but I spent all that
money and bought as many obscure movies
on amazon as I possibly could and was
just watching like tons and tons of
obscure movies like stuff that was like
a hundred dollars for a DVD because it
was completely out of print I would hunt
for like the really expensive stuff that
like nobody else had because I was like
I need to see this and I think um sadly
like that that because of the the death
of the video stores I feel like that's
that's like dying away like you know
people wanting to hunt down these
obscure things and like the collectors
and stuff I mean like and I'm guilty of
it too because like I I own 6,000 DVDs
and I haven't bought a DVD in two years
because I now go well I have it all on
netflix and like I I justify it in my
head even though I know hey I should buy
a DVD right now like I go see him in
theaters I'll like rent the movie on
like you know amazon
crime or whatever but like for some
reason I just like I've now somehow in
my head convinced myself oh well you
know it'll be on netflix that's that's a
netflix movie that's one that I'll wait
for netflix I don't need that you know
um and I find it I find it interesting
that like you know that's you know we
become so complacent within our society
that were able to just write off wanting
to own something and wanting to collect
it and so you know I think like true
cinephiles are dying away because like I
even though I love film and I'm I'm a
student of film to the day I die I
definitely have started to feel like I'm
no longer a truce in a file because I
don't go out and search for those things
anymore the things that brought me into
loving this it's like you know we don't
have that that that video store that's
sanctuary to go in and get those things
anymore and I think it's I think it's
sad I think it's a sad sad thing and you
know it's uh I I definitely feel like
you know I'm 23 years old and when I
have when I have kids I I definitely
feel like it's going to be sad that
they'll never be able to go to like a
video store to look through a bunch of
DVDs and stuff
you